cinnamon sugar butter find out which
celebrity makes the best cinnamon rolls
that's right guys i'm gonna test out
three celebrity cinnamon roll recipes
delicious and chris is gonna try them in
a blind taste test and decide which is
the best now cover your ears because you
can't know this next part that's your
eyes what
our three celebrities are christina tosi
chrissy teigen and snoop dogg all right
i'm gonna go make these yeah chris has
got to go work yeah
wait let's have a secret handshake roll
roll roll
and roll butt touch throw roll roll roll
santa and then we have to look dead
[Laughter]
first up we've got christina tosi she
has you combine warm milk a little bit
of water and active dry yeast in a small
bowl you'll whisk that together and let
it stand for about five minutes or until
it becomes foamy then in a standing
mixer you combine flour sugar and salt
then you'll attach a dough hook to mix
the dry ingredients on a low speed add
one egg and an egg yolk
melted butter and what she calls the
yeast concoction you let this mix for
about six minutes until it becomes a
large sticky dough transfer that to a
workspace and shape it into a ball then
you'll grease a medium sized bowl and
put the dough inside it make sure you
put the dough seam side down cover with
a towel and let it sit for one hour or
until it doubles in size while the dough
rises you'll make the cinnamon sugar
filling mix together brown sugar butter
salt and cinnamon combine that in a
small bowl until it's all incorporated
together next you're gonna punch the
proof dough down which was my favorite
part of this recipe and a lot of fun
transfer it to a well-floured surface
then you're gonna use a rolling pin or
she even suggests a wine bottle to roll
the dough out into a 16 inch square once
you've made your almost perfect square
you're gonna take your cinnamon sugar
filling and spread that all over the
dough roll that dough up into a big
tight tube cut that into 12 even pieces
i tried my best to make it even place
these in an eight by eight inch pyrex
deep dish leaving one inch between them
i wasn't exactly sure how to do that so
i just stacked them on top of each other
let these guys rise until they double in
size about one to two hours then you'll
bake these guys at 375 degrees
fahrenheit for about 20 minutes in a
standing mixer you'll combine butter and
cream cheese with a paddle attachment
you'll mix it on high for about a minute
then reduce the speed to low and add the
confectioners sugar vanilla and salt
whip that at a high speed until it's
smooth and fluffy for fun you can
transfer your frosting to a piping bag
then pipe it on top of the buns in a
lattice pattern and there you have it
christina tosi's cinnamon roll that
looks really good i like the look of
this one a lot i'll let you try i'm
gonna have a little bit too wow
that was really good the filling is nice
and cinnamon sugary it's got both of
those flavors nicely balanced it's gooey
on the inside but the dough is also
still flaky this is a really good
cinnamon roll that was number one i'm
gonna go make number two
oh my god
you realize that it sounded like right
i'm gonna make a number two yeah
i'm just saving you for all right making
poop jokes
next up we've got chrissy teigen serving
us a twist on the classic cinnamon roll
she calls these cardamom coffee buns but
they use the same method as a cinnamon
roll in a small pot you'll combine milk
water and butter heat that mixture up
until the butter has melted and it's
reached 110 degrees fahrenheit or is
warm to the touch add this to the dry
ingredients along with the egg
and then mix that until a dough forms
transfer it to a lightly floured surface
where you're going to knead it for about
four minutes until it becomes a smooth
ball then take a medium sized greased
bowl and add the dough to it and cover
loosely with plastic wrap and you only
have to let this dough sit for 10
minutes while the dough rests you're
going to make the filling you'll combine
brown sugar and instead of cinnamon
ground cardamom and add a little butter
you'll mix this for about three to four
minutes until it's creamy then on a
lightly floured surface you're going to
roll out your dough into a 9 by 18 inch
rectangle because we hadn't let it rest
that long i was surprised how easy it
was to roll out chrissy's dough once
you've got your rectangle done you'll
take your cardamom filling and spread
that evenly all over the dough starting
from one of the shorter sides you're
gonna roll up your dough into a tight
tube cut it into 16 even slices and then
transfer to a buttered nine inch round
i found it a little tight but they
managed to all fit cover that with
plastic wrap and let sit for about an
hour or until they've doubled in size
when the buns are ready you'll pour
heavy cream over the top and bake that
at
375 degrees for about 20 minutes it
actually took me closer to 25 minutes
but everyone's oven is different while
the buns are in the oven we're gonna
make our glaze combine confectioners
sugar vanilla and coffee whisk that
together until it's smooth
take the buns out of the oven and while
they're still warm cover it with the
coffee glaze chrissy suggests for a
pretty presentation flip the buns over
and serve them upside down and there you
have it chrissy teigen's cardamon coffee
buns a twist on the classic cinnamon
roll whoa
very different yes it's upside down
it's upside down yeah
what
hmm
there's something in it that tastes
almost like savory there's cardamom
cardamom
yes the fact that it's cardamom instead
of cinnamon is really interesting it
definitely makes them taste really
unique i can imagine eating this one and
being really satisfied having it with a
a cup of coffee
more so than the first one well i'm
going to make the last one all right and
we'll see
who wins i'm just going to have one more
you are eating some kind of sugar combo
this is a huge bite and last up we've
got snoop dogg in a small saucepan he
combines milk with a little bit of water
and heats this for two to three minutes
or until warm to the touch transfer the
liquid to a large bowl and spread
instant yeast on top then you'll add one
egg sugar and some butter and stir that
together i found stirring with a spatula
left a lot of clumps so i switched to a
whisk instead then you'll add flour and
salt and mix together until a dough
starts to form
transfer this to a stand mixer and
attach a dough hook beat this on medium
speed for about six to seven minutes or
he suggests you can knead it by hand for
eight minutes then you're going to
transfer the dough into a medium greased
bowl i had to shape the dough with my
hands into a ball because it didn't
really form one in the stand mixer then
you're going to let this sit for about
an hour to an hour and a half until it
doubles in size next we'll make the
filling combine brown sugar and some
cinnamon and then we'll make his glaze
combine confectioners sugar heavy cream
and my favorite a little bit of bourbon
mix this together until there's no
clumps when the dough is ready transfer
it to a lightly floured surface and roll
it out into a 16 by 18 inch rectangle
this next step snoop does a little
differently from the others he has you
brush the dough with melted butter and
then sprinkle on the cinnamon sugar
instead of mixing the butter into the
filling then starting from the longer
side roll the dough into a tight log
when you get to the end brush the edges
with a little bit of water to seal the
roll i found this was actually necessary
because the dough is very dry then
you'll cut the log into 12 even slices
transfer to a buttered 9 by 13 baking
dish
and bake at 350 degrees fahrenheit for
about 25 minutes
and make sure to rotate the dish halfway
through so all of the rolls bake evenly
once the rolls are baked remove them
from the oven and drizzle the bourbon
glaze over them while they're still warm
and there you have it snoop dogg
cinnamon rolls with a bourbon glaze whoa
wow wow you're very impressed with this
i am this one's like the most beautiful
one
the cakiness of it is really good
it's definitely cakey it's definitely
drier
and the it's almost a biscuity it is
almost biscuit it's almost more like a
biscuit
i thought i would actually like it the
least but it's now it's close i feel
like
you don't know it it's really hard
between all three should we get all
three backgrounds let's get all three
out here let's get all three
eating
i'm just gonna take one more one last
quick bite
the one that rolled me over with the
fabulousness
uh was number one
that was
christina
oh
oh okay she is the dessert queen i would
say
that makes sense i'm so tired
i love you and we do
that's a wrap that's a wrap on rolls uh
that's a wrong
[Music]